[Music]
from pokemon unite
to league of legends and fortnite
all right listen up these are some of
the most popular video games in the
world
and behind them is a chinese company you
may not be familiar with hensen is
china's largest social media company it
is also the world's largest video game
company by revenue last year it reported
more than 22 billion dollars in revenue
from smartphone games and nearly 7
billion dollars from pc games but that
growth could hit a roadblock since late
2020 beijing has embarked on a clampdown
of its home-grown tech giants and
tencent is one of them it's facing more
scrutiny over its business practices
including its allegedly anti-competitive
behaviors regulators are also concerned
that young chinese citizens may become
addicted to video games regulations are
always looming in china from now on
they can only become stricter and
stricter we take a look at tencent's
video game portfolio over the years to
see how it became a giant in the
industry and what beijing's regulatory
crackdown could mean for the company's
global empire
tencent made its entrance into the video
game world with one of the biggest names
in the industry league of legends
but before explaining how tencent got
there you first need to understand that
it didn't start off as a video game
company the chinese tech giant has
businesses in music video streaming and
search engines but it's best known for
its social networking app wechat which
is everything from handling payments to
booking doctor's appointments the app
has over 1.2 billion monthly active
users and that's been key to reaching a
vast network of gamers in china there's
no company on the planet that has this
advantage that that tencent has sarah
khan toto is an independent video game
industry consultant in japan and he's
been watching this sector for more than
a decade they've turned wechat into a
gaming platform and they also use it as
an incredibly powerful
distribution tool marketing tool user
acquisition tool they're making
aggressive use of that
the company has been building its own
online games since 2003 developing some
relatively simple games like these
[Music]
two more sophisticated ones
over the years tencent has also tried to
export some of them but they failed to
take off in the west the best um example
is probably honor of kings
which is you know the world's biggest
mobile game by revenue very well made
but they are you know designed to appeal
to chinese gamers for example the world
building characters the stories the
narratives
video game industry analysts say some of
tencent's flops may have accelerated the
company's foreign investments
and this brings us back to league of
legends in 2009 the company became the
official chinese distributor of the
us-developed game it's not a casual game
it's not a very easy to play game after
launch
it just
developed into a crowd pleaser toto says
this kind of growth helped push tencent
to make a bold move with a los angeles
startup in 2011 they made their first
big international investment in a gaming
company into riot games which
operates one of the world's biggest pc
games league of legends right now
tencent paid 400 million dollars for a
93 stake in the american company and
four years later it scooped up the
remaining seven percent taking full
control of riot games
games they needed funds to scale the
company league of legends became big so
quickly and on a such an international
scale mainly because of 10 cents
investment
with 10 cents backing league of legends
monthly players have grown by almost 10
fold and in the past decade the game has
made some 20 billion dollars in revenue
this early success has basically
triggered something inside tencent right
and it showed to tencent internally that
there's a big opportunity not only in
china but also outside of china if you
make the right moves in terms of
investing the success of league of
legends helped kick start a shopping
spree tencent made its second big move
in 2012 by investing in another american
game developer epic games the company
behind fortnite activision blizzard
which is north america's biggest video
game publisher by market value
supercell the finnish developer behind
clash of clans bluehole the south korean
game maker behind the battle royale
sensation pubg the chinese company
hasn't just acquired stakes but also
found ways to collaborate roblox the
online game platform popular with young
kids entered into a joint venture with
tencent to make its entry into china and
the pokemon company worked with tencent
to develop a new game called pokemon
unite and as video game companies saw a
big boom during the pandemic with people
stuck at home tencen has already closed
12 game related deals overseas this year
tencent has to expand globally in the
gaming market because it needs to seek
on more growth it'll also become easier
for them to get exclusive distribution
rights for these games and that also
further um cements their dominance in
the whole market too
but this dominance at home has raised
concerns among regulators about the
gaming habits of young people the worst
crackdown that tencent has faced so far
is probably the 2018 episode when the
chinese government suspended approval of
new games for about a year then this
year as part of a larger regulatory
crackdown beijing began looking more
closely at tencent in august a chinese
state newspaper called online games
opium for the mind later the article was
taken down then republished without the
phrase opium for the mind after the
article's publication tencent saw a big
sell-off and his share price dropped
about 10 in just one day so there's a
lot of confusion whether
that article represents any actual
policy agenda so tencent has pledged to
enforce tougher rules than required by
the authorities young gamers will only
be allowed to play for one hour on
weekdays and two hours on weekends and
holidays
we haven't seen on the current
regulatory storm
really hit the core of tencent yet when
other companies took a very big hit it
also
raises the question
whether tencent will be the next toto
says this type of uncertainty at home
might push tencent to see that the
bigger opportunities are overseas
tencent is most likely to even more
focus on its global gaming business
going forward you want to make sure that
you use your capital effectively outside
of china to offset certain risks tencent
said it's committed to growing the games
sector in china while looking at
potential investments abroad that can
bring strategic value to the company
i think that tencent is going to try to
acquire even more uh studios even more
developers outside its whole market and
that could mean that the next
blockbuster games you'll be playing
could have 10 cent behind them
[Music]